four three two one booyah yeah no main
event from Madison Square Garden so far
the rumors were John Jones and Gustafson
but I don't know I don't know I don't
know why that hasn't materialized are
they just waiting to announce it till
after the whole Connor khabib thing why
would they do that
I think if they announce something it's
got to be this weekend I mean what isn't
it November 3rd or something that's soon
so it's on my percent monitor really a
month today's the third right second
today's the second day's a second yeah
[ __ ] man
that ain't good I yeah maybe they just
don't want to steal any shine from the
counter could beat by the record yet I
think they were banking on Jones to for
that main event but it's been tricky to
fill that slot but also why not have if
you're gonna do this why not announce
Nate Diaz does import is your main event
that's a great main event
I can ride with that what I mean that
and then advant then announce John Jones
and Gus spinner John Jones and Kane if
you want to but the main event is to be
announced versus to be determined I've
never seen a [ __ ] pay-per-view a
month out that says to be announced
versus to be determined in the main
event does that mean they have somebody
booked and then the not an opponent form
and they're not in announcing it or they
just like decided to just be funny and
write both first that's a very good
point it's a good point it's a very good
point I would say they have no idea I
think you just nailed it I think they
have a guy that they want to fight
another guy
I'd heard actually heard from you Jones
versus Kane that was the rumor mill that
birdie told me
yeah that would god I'm all over there I
would be all over that this cards
actually better in this weekend's card
style benders frighten Derek Brunson
that's a great fight leaper that's the
sleeper on that card right there
we got Luke Rockhold Chris Weidman - oh
that's a good fight - job by David
branching st. where is Robin Weidman on
there at the bottom middle what
an order yet oh wow what what things all
over the place puzzle guy rents the UFC
website took the month off
Rockhold vs. Weidman very interesting
that what